BASTIEN LEGRAS: Hi, I guess
you can hear me.
So my name is Bastien Legras.
I am a cloud solution engineer
based in Google Paris office.
I work with Christoph that
you just saw before me.
And we cover together Southern
Europe, so France, Italy, and
Spain, and Portugal.
And in this session--
it's a 20-minute session--
we're going to cover mobile
from a more technical
perspective.
So we're going to cover
Cloud Endpoints.
Maybe you heard about it.
It's a feature of App Engine.
And we're going to cover, as
well, Cloud Mobile Backends.
That has been announced at
Google I/O. And I will show an
extract of the video
of Google I/O.
So first, Cloud Endpoints.
For those who don't know
already, the idea with Cloud
Endpoints is to accelerate the
time to market for your mobile
applications, or web
applications as well, in
HTML5, by autocoding the layer
that connects your mobile app
to our backend.
So you just have to focus
on the UI, on the user
experience, and the features of
your game, and don't worry
about the [INAUDIBLE]
that will access the
backend services.
And we do that for
Android and iOS.
The other topic, the Mobile
Backend Starter, and we're
going to go deep dive into these
features, is a set of
APIs, of services in the App
Engine, that will also help
you do stuff like
authentication, messaging--
so push from the cloud--
continuous queries-- we'll have
a short video on that--
and, again, help you be more
productive and focus more on
your app rather than on the
technical underground.
So first this one minute
interview with Fred Sauer and
Mandy Waite who are in developer
relations, also at
Google, based in the US, and
she's in London, I guess.
Telling what is the strategy
with cloud backend.
So for that, because we don't
have an output, I will try to
use the mic, hoping we
won't have feedback.
FRED SAUER: So how viable or
recommended would it be to
build a backend service for
mobile apps around Google
Cloud Endpoints?
MANDY WAITE: All right, I think,
really, that's probably
the biggest use case for
Cloud Endpoints,
building mobile backends.
And we say backends, again,
we're talking about the
general sense of it,
rather than the App
Engine sense of backends.
If you want to build an
application that will provide
resources and services that
are consumed by mobile
devices, then Cloud Endpoints
will do that for
you out of the box.
I think, pretty much,
we covered most
of that in the slides.
But the documentation is pretty
extensive, both for
Java and for Python.
So you can learn more about how
to use Cloud Endpoints.
You can check that out.
There was also Google I/O.
FRED SAUER: There was, yes.
MANDY WAITE: You can actually
get a lot of information from
Google I/O sessions from
previous years.
FRED SAUER: Very good.
All right, your turn.
MANDY WAITE: My turn.
BASTIEN LEGRAS: I'm not sure you
have heard very well, but
you have the captions.
So as you understand, the idea
is to really help startups
being more productive and so to
try more applications, more
games, on Android and iOS.
So let's talk about--
sorry--
so where Christoph left
you last, which
is the Cloud Endpoints.
So as I said, the idea is that
all the essential components
that all mobile applications
need are, basically,
autocoded--
when I say autocoded, it's
like a wrapper is coded.
So you just have to--
if you are building your own
APIs, in the App Engine
backend, then you will manage
with the cloud backend to
expose these APIs, and also have
the client side that will
be written by the App Engine
toolkit, so you can directly
start from that.
And the development process
is quite simple.
So you write your API
backend first.
That's where you need to start,
at the data design, and
of course, the methods
you want to expose.
And then, what you can do is
either annotate your API
backend code, because this is
the annotation that will help
the toolkit to generate the
wrapper, or you can use the
plug-in for Eclipse, if you
are an Eclipse developer.
And by the way, who is an
Eclipse developer here?
Quite a number of you.
So the two options are here.
Then what you want to do is to
generate the client library,
of course, from which you will
then write your mobile app.
And again, two solutions.
You can use the SH tool,
endpoints.sh, or use the
plug-in directly
within Eclipse.
And then, for the last step, you
can start working on your
client app and, as I said,
focus on your UI, on the
business logic on the client
side of your application.
So now, some extract of the
Google I/O slides as well.
So they were building an
application live in the demo.
And I encourage you to go have
a look at this video.
It's a 30-minute long video.
And I'll show you after the
link, where geeks want to
finally choose us for using
maps, et cetera.
And the idea here, as you can
see, that application on the
left is using the Mobile
Backend Starter Client,
directly connected, and
the Android Client ID.
So the ID that will also help
identify your application with
the backend to connect
to each other.
What you can do as well-- so now
I'm more focusing on the
backend itself-- is that you
can directly store your
application data in two
kinds of storage.
I don't know if you can read,
but there is the App Engine
data store, which we have now
renamed by the way, as Cloud
Datastore, from which you can
connect from anywhere.
And the idea is that we now
have even four storage
mechanisms with Google
Cloud platform.
You have this Cloud Datastore,
which is a NoSQL, [INAUDIBLE]
datastore.
You can store terabytes of
objects if you want.
Here we have, also, the Google
Cloud storage, which is object
storage, more like
a file system.
And we will have a session
on that this
afternoon at 3:00, I think.
That will be me again.
I'll do a quick demo.
For those who don't know, there
is also CloudSQL, which
is MySQL 5.5 managed in our
cloud data centers.
And you can directly access
using SQL queries at the port
3306 from Compute
Engine today.
And at the end, because I
wanted to focus more on
storage, there is also another
storage mechanism which is
more in the Compute
Engine world.
And we will discuss about
Compute Engine a lot.
This afternoon, I will do
a demo of that as well.
It's called the Persistent
Disk.
So Persistent Disk is a
five-system mounted network
share that you can share across
apps to 16 machines.
And you can format yourself.
And you can use that to
boot your machines--
very convenient and scalable.
Then other features that you
may need from the cloud
backend for your application
is asynchronous processing.
So you can use Task Queues.
Task Queues is one of the top
components in App Engine.
So you can directly create your
tasks, store them, and
they will executive so you
can run your batches.
I don't know why I am
using my keyboard.
So then the push notification,
that's
something also really key.
This is something we've been
using a lot at Google since
day one because for Android,
with Google Play--
so former Android market--
when we want to push application
updates so your
phone is going to download them
automatically, the idea
that we've been using that
type of technology.
So cloud messaging--
so the phone stays quite
connected, if you
want, with the cloud.
So you can push from your app's
backend to the users a
notification.
That's very useful.
Let's say in a gaming
environment, or if people want
to chat-- we use it as well
for Google Hangout--
renamed, it was Google
Talk before.
We cannot predict when the
notification will come.
And cloud messaging is the
right toolkit for that.
So you can really push messages,
technical messages,
to the app instances you get.
And we have also worked
on the iOS world.
So as you can see here, Apple
push notification service,
which is similar to VPN, similar
to push also with
messages from the backend
to iOS instances.
Another example-- so I hope, in
the next video, I will show
and you can hear, so
you understand
how it works as well.
But you see, still, on the right
side, the Mobile Backend
Starter and the Client Library
on the left, showing how you
can do that kind of
registration and
push messages directly.
And then serving and
processing images.
If you are developing, I don't
know, a camera for the phone,
or a game that needs image
processing, like social
network, that's also a
service we provide
on the cloud platform.
So something you directly use
from cloud storage to store
the static images.
And then you can process them
in the image service to
convert them from a format to
another, to do, I don't know,
color modifications, stuff like
this, or push lighter
images to your phone, if, when
you're want to have a mosaics,
family pictures.
So that's the type, usually,
of usage we see
on the image services.
Another one is the search.
So of course, we do a lot
of things in search.
And now App Engine--
so I think this was an App
Engine in the March version--
we now provide full
text search.
And that's also something very
useful in the mobile use case.
So we can do full text search
on the backend directly from
the phone as well.
And geo proximity again, if
you wanted to search in a
geolocalization context.
The tasks we were talking about,
the Task Queues, now
there's also the
schedule task.
If you need to have schedule
task for your application,
like, I don't know, recurrent
updates, or if there is a
message that you need to pass at
the certain time of the day
to your users.
That's also a component of App
Engine you may want to use in
a mobile scenario.
Now I heard a question this
morning of someone asking
what's the integration between
the App Engine
and the Compute Engine?
So we have been working
on that.
And the idea is that if you
have a heavy task that you
don't want to run using App
Engine backend, but you need
really a sever to do that, or
rack of servers, you can do
that from Compute Engine and
orchestrate it from App Engine.
So the idea here-- that's
what we call VM Engine--
is that you can imagine
you create a task.
And this task is going to be
sent to a cluster of GC
machines that you can start from
App Engine, execute the
task, send back the
result, and then
shut down the mission.
Maybe you've heard at I/O that
we now do [INAUDIBLE], so that
is very useful.
If you have really heavy video
processing task for which you
need a heavy CPU server.
You can really imagine that the
task is generated by App
Engine, executed by Compute
Engine, result is sent back,
and App Engine [INAUDIBLE].
Very convenient,
and all that is
integrated using Task Queues.
Continuous Query also is
quite interesting.
So I would like to show an
extract of the I/O session on
that, so you can better
understand what was the use
case, and how it works because
it's a five-step scenario.
And that's, I think, very
interesting also for gaming or
mobile apps in general.
So we're going to try
with this one.
But worse case is there
are captions, OK?
So a two- or three-minute video,
there are captions .
And I think I already--
no, let's try that way.
DAVID CHANDLER: Well, I'll tell
you about the Continuous
Query capability that we're
going to use to do that.
So this is a feature of the
Mobile Backend Starter project
that uses several App Engine
features as well.
There's a API and preview called
Prospective Search.
And what that does is, anytime
data comes in that matches the
parameters of your query, then
App Engine will notify your
app on the server side
that some matching
data has been found.
So we're going to use that
to our advantage here.
Any time a new location update
gets posted, then our app will
get notified on the
server side.
And the Mobile Backend Starter
project takes that further and
will send a GCM message
to our app running on
the phone as well.
So the flow looks like this.
In step one, a new location
update comes from the phone,
gets put in the server.
In step two, the App Engine
Prospective Search API
notifies the server side
part of our Mobile
Backend Starter app.
That sends a GCM message, Google
Cloud Messaging, to the
client in step three.
Then, in step four we re-query
to get the latest data from
the server.
And then, finally, step five, we
draw the markers on the map
with that most recent data.
So I'm going to go now write
the code that actually does
this in our app.
So we'll again take a look
into our map activity.
And the first thing we want
to do is write a query--
I'm just going to scroll down
a little bit here--
that will go out and get
the geek locations.
So we paste in some code here,
query geeks, and show you what
that looks like.
All the capability that I just
described on that slide is
called Continuous Queries is
what we're calling it right
now in this project.
And so the first part of our
query is to write a handler
that will receive the
results, so we have
a OnComplete handler.
And we're just going to draw
markers, simple enough.
Then, to actually register
the query, we call
getCloudBackend.
clearAllSubscription.
Now the notion of a Continuous
Query, you can subscribe to
queries on the server.
So we want to clear any existing
subscriptions and
then set up a new one.
So we say a new Cloud
Query for kind geek.
We're just going to get the top
50 geeks sorted in order
of the most recent
location updates.
And we're going to make the
scope future and past.
So again, this is a feature of
the Mobile Backend Starter
that lets you say, I want to be
notified of future matches
to this query, as
well as present.
And if you think about the
amount of code that you would
have to write to do all
manually, setting up GCM,
keeping track of this data,
is actually a very nice
convenience.
BASTIEN LEGRAS: It
stops there.
So it was to better illustrate
this concept.
So this is the slide Christoph
was showing before.
But now, you maybe more
understand how all the pieces
of the puzzle come together.
So it's a recap of all these
features, as you can see.
So we really believe with that
kind of architectures, App
Engine is a great
orchestrater.
So it's like the chef or puppet
if you use that kind of
technology to talk to
all the services.
We think that with
doing a lot of
integration between the services--
the team in Google, it's
hundreds of engineers we have
in US and in Europe.
But the idea is to have
a common set of APIs.
And you will see in the demo
this afternoon on the Compute
Engine, I will show what is a
project, how the console looks
like, and how you can activate
your services, and how you can
connect each together
when it comes to
design and video projects.
So in this capacity, App Engine
is talking to your
devices, whether they
are Android or iOS.
It can talk directly from here
and push to Android devices
using Google Cloud Messaging
technology or using Apple push
notification technology.
So that's the two ways you can
communicate from the cloud to
the devices.
That was the monetization piece
AdMob that Christoph
mentioned earlier.
You have all these App
Engine features--
we've been covering these in the
App Engine session-- that
are, of course, useful in a
mobile development scenario.
The Task Queries as I mentioned
earlier, and that
you can use to do some batch
processing on Compute Engine
for heavy loads, schedule tasks,
search APIs, and log
the APIs as usual on App Engine
that you can also
imagine, because now we are
plugging together BigQuery,
which is our big data engine,
and some other parts of
Google, like Google Analytics,
Google AdSense, the logs here
from App Engine.
So you can also analyze the way
all your users are playing
or are using your application
to better understand what
works, what doesn't work,
in an application.
So you can optimize it,
whether it's difficult
[? seniority ?]--
and again, to make sure that
people are not stuck in level
four because there's a challenge
that was maybe too
much difficult for the user.
Or if it's a feature
that no one uses.
So that's a great way, using
the logs and BigQuery to
detect that kind of optimization
you should do on
your application.
And if you are very hungry--
[APPLAUSE]
BASTIEN LEGRAS: Thank
you very much.